we've got more breaking news this time
from Russia where an American reporter
has been arrested and accused of
Espionage Russian security officials
claim that Evan gerskovic he works for
the Wall Street Journal was trying to
obtain classified information Charlie
dagada has more on the arrest it was
revealed just a few hours ago Charlie
good morning to you what can you tell us
about this one
yeah good morning Gail he was arrested
hundreds of miles east of Moscow and the
spokesman for President Putin said he
was caught red-handed those are his
words collecting information about the
Russian military complex he's accused of
Espionage that carries a 20-year
sentence the 31 year old reporter has
been working for the Wall Street Journal
in Moscow since January 2022 but he had
previous experience reporting from
Russia in a statement Wall Street
Journal vehemently denies the
allegations and seeks his immediate
release Gail boy caught red-handed never
a good sign coming from Russia but
Charlie I want to ask you this because
you've reported inside Russia for years
and years in your experience what does
this arrest mean to you when you first
heard it what'd you think
well my first thought was uh oh you know
we haven't been there since the invasion
began since Russia invaded Ukraine for
precisely this reason now in March of
last year President Putin and the
government put in these new laws saying
the spread of knowingly false
information about Russian armed forces
would be illegal the spread of knowingly
false information about Russian State
bodies would be illegal that made it
difficult for westerners Americans
especially to work within Russia itself
because as we know some of the reporting
that we've done in Ukraine as far as the
Russians are concerned is fake it's
false reporting so for us to be able to
report inside Russia which would
obviously be helpful is impossible right
now there are only a handful of Western
reporters in Russia let alone Americans
Gail yeah there's there's a reason for
that Charlie jagata thank you reporting
from London